face aux démenti de Kiev et à
l'indignation de la communauté
internationale la Russie persiste et si
selon Moscou les autorités ukrainiennes
fabriquent bel et bien une bombe salle
c'est-à-dire un engin explosif chargé de
composants radioactifs
ce sujet sera au cœur des débats du
Conseil de sécurité à l'ONU les démentis
infondées de nos collègues occidentaux
et l'argument selon lequel c'est la
Russie qui prépare une attaque similaire
pour accuser le régime des elenski ne
sont pas sérieux
Moscou a avancé pour la première fois
ses accusations dimanche pour prouver sa
bonne foi le ministre ukrainien des
Affaires étrangères a demandé à l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
d'envoyer des inspecteurs sur les deux
sites incriminés par les Russes une
visite qui devrait se dérouler dans les
prochains jours de son côté la
communauté internationale dénonce les
mensonges dangereux du régime russe
les alliés de l'OTAN rejettent cette
allégation la Russie ne doit pas
utiliser cela comme un prétexte à une
escalade les accusations du Kremlin
interviennent après une série de
défaites militaires russes et alors que
les troupes ukrainiennes poursuivent
leur contre-offensive dans l'Est et le
Sud du pays